hey guys why is self discipline so
important well the short answer to it is
you can't reach your goals if you don't
even know how to control yourself
self-discipline is about mastering your
mind so you'll be able to master your
impulses and your desires of what you
want right now with what you want most
out of life which is your goals so
self-discipline helps you to focus on
doing what you need to do to achieve
your goals even if you don't feel like
it and that builds true character
so in this video I'm gonna give you
three habits that's gonna help you to
build self-discipline let's get to it
[Music]
mistakes by mistakes make you strong now
just very quick if your first time here
on my channel I'm Daniel and welcome to
D LM model lifestyle subscribe and also
click that notification bell so you
won't miss any of the next videos now
let's start with the first thing that
will help you to build self-discipline
focus on knowing what is right instead
of what feels right what I mean here
well if you want to improve your self
discipline you need to change your
current routine of doing things and
that's gonna feel uncomfortable and
difficult for most people why is it so
difficult well it's because all your
daily behaviors form habits and that is
controlled by the basal ganglia of your
brain which focuses on emotions patterns
and memories so let me explain this a
little better when a certain behavior
becomes a habit it starts to work in
autopilot so then it feels normal
to you and it feels right but it doesn't
mean it is right so you have to make an
active decision to break the old habits
and build new ones
even if it feels wrong now you need to
know it will take some time to build new
habits because you'll be at war with
your own brain but if you stay
determined if you stay consistent you'll
get there and once you get there your
new habits will also feel right and your
life will be a lot easier you gotta eat
healthier some of you might say yes
Daniel we've heard that before
but do you really understand it the next
plane is studies show that low blood
sugar often make you feel tired
and you have low energy so you feel weak
and it lowers your resolve some of you
might even feel grumpy I know I am
sometimes when I'm hungry but the big
problem here is that your brain is not
functioning at its best and this
influences your whole life because your
ability to handle your work social life
relationships and so forth is a lot
lower than usual
so just stop it from happening in the
first place by just eating more healthy
and also more regularly give your body
the energy it needs to always perform
its best if you make this a habit your
brain will be able to focus on your
goals and it will be easier for you to
have self-discipline take breaks and
reward yourself if you are too hard on
yourself all the time for trying to
build self-discipline chances are that
you're gonna fail you're gonna be
disappointed in yourself so when you
start this journey of teaching yourself
to have more self-discipline
you gotta take breaks
and also reward yourself when you
accomplish those smaller goals and you
can schedule it into your routine for
example I ate super healthy in the week
and it's a lot easier to do that because
I know that I'm gonna reward myself at
the end of the week so Monday to
Saturday
I eat super healthy but then when sunday
comes I know I'm gonna eat a meal with
no rules so I'm gonna eat pizza or
hamburgers ice cream whatever you name
it and I'm not gonna feel guilty about
it because it's my reward for having
self-discipline from Monday to Saturday
for eating healthy if you want to
discipline yourself for saving money for
example schedule a day of the month
where you go out and you treat yourself
where you go out and you go to the
movies when you do something that's that
you really love to do but for the rest
of the time just take some cash review
and leave your credit card at home so
you'll know that you'll be able to save
money because you don't have any other
money in with you only the money that
you took with you but your credit card
that's at home the self discipline is
not easy at the start but it is worth it
if you achieve your goals now just a
bonus step get rid of all temptations
for example if you want to lose weight
then why are those chocolate bars in the
fridge or in the closet see what I mean
here your desire to achieve your goals
need to be a lot higher a lot more than
your desire to eat unhealthy or those
bad habits that you have and remember
it's gonna be a lot harder for you to
have self-discipline if you have all
temptations around you all the time get
rid of it because if it is out of sight
it is out of mind
now remember there's a lot of other
things that you can do to try and reach
your goals but only self discipline will
give you a long-term success be
consistent start today and change your
life now if you're new here on my
channel you might like one of these
videos and I'll see you there
cheers guys
[Music]